wittmann elvira uns herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video ich muss ich erst
mal kurz zurechtfinden ich setze euch
wie ihr weg an einer etwas mit die
position ist die gleichen ich habe mir
auf jeden fall eine etwas andere
location gebaut und ja das ganze hat
folgenden grund
herzlich willkommen beim eine neue form
also ich weiß ich ganz genau ob das mein
neues format wird aber ich habe auf
jeden fall war
ich muss erstmal schauen gibt euch
ankommt wie das feiert abwehr bot drauf
habt und wenn ihr back dort habt dann
macht das natürlich gerne öfter ja ich
weiß es auch nicht ich bin gerade auf
den crypt einfach so andere länder zu
probieren
ihr wisst was ich meine die sachen aus
anderen ländern zu probieren
irgendwelche süßigkeiten irgendwelche
cool verschiedenen sachen miteinander zu
vergleichen
ich hab mir letztens auch schon mal
irgendwann japanische youtube angeschaut
und alle sonst weisheit und wir heute
habe ich mich ganz besonders belegen
dass hier die erste folge meines neuen
formates das heißt einfach deutscher ist
bla bla bla bla bla verstehe er dass er
nicht mit es gibt halt immer das
deutsche produkt und dann noch zwei oder
drei produkte aus anderen ländern und
die probiere ich vergleiche die
miteinander und vielleicht bestelle ich
in zukunft nur noch energy drink aus
amerika oder asien
wenn ich mal lecker schmeckt also
natürlich sieht ja noch relativ in der
aus deswegen kleine momente wir haben
erst drei deutschen martina effekt kennt
wahrscheinlich jeder von euch und
monster wissen auch die meisten können
wird auf jeden fall selbst gebaut sich
feiert also koma trinkt mehr dann haben
wir hier karabach das ist die asiatische
version von energy drink oder kommt
zumindest aus asien habe ich mir
bestimmt nicht letzten angekommen
die renten sind irgendwelche
fußballspieler drauf warum auch immer
und dann haben wir noch ein paket hat es
eben angekommen und zwar hier der
amerikanische energy drink drin sein
425 und fahren wir hier a und b queen
oder naturally and artists weeks later
and amazing marke asiatische marke
amerikanische marke und das ist
irgendwie auch momentan ist gefunden
aber die einmal dazu gestellt habt war
energy drink currywurst daher mich hat
einfach interessiert wie das schmeckt
aber nicht vielmehr erst mal bereitet
ich habe gedacht mein standard getränk
wird bin ich nicht mit reid einfach
international ist und schmeckt also kann
ich jetzt schon sagen das hast du ja
wenn euch das format gefällt habe ich
noch gar nicht gesagt dass auf jeden
fall noch nach oben da jetzt öfter sehen
wollt und schreibt auch auf jeden fall
mal in die kommentare was ich noch zu
testen soll auf verschiedenen nationen
vergleichen seit tagen bei 15.000
leitgeb das ganze nochmal spiel gespannt
und ganz wichtig wir machen jetzt
erstmal hier ihre dose aus und schicken
das weihnachts klar einfach um zu sehen
wie das auto das auge schmeckt mit
pulver das macht eigentlich keinen sinn
weil wer trinkt nicht auf einer dose
sondern macht der dose aufgeschüttete
sind klar aber ich möchte schon mal die
pappel sehen hingegen die genau gleich
aus nur jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
model ich grün alter der diebels teil
aus tut was vergleich das mal der ist
einfach ein bisschen doch leider wieder
auf wie das so gestellt dass neben
projekt bin ich mal gespannt auf den
amerikanischen woher ich übe täglich
nach vanille ich liebe wandel
ja also ich das ganze aus ich bin gegen
die gerade paradies also ich mag die
band echt gerne deswegen teile wirklich
ich finde das hier sieht 100 prozent aus
wie bier
das sieht auch geil und das sieht alles
viel typisches deutsches energie erzeugt
was man ab und zu mal mit irgendwelchen
alkoholischen getränken mit ich würde
sagen es ist natürlich wichtig aus den
dosen zu probieren einfach um diesen
guten geschmack mit dabei zu haben und
ich würde sagen ich fange einfach mal
mit effekt an
ich weiß eigentlich geschlecht wer
richtig lecker kann man dringend auf
jeden fall aber da sehe ich auch die
meisten von euch haben das
wahrscheinlich schon mal probiert so
hier diese monster drinking bis zum
schluss und ich mache jetzt einfach mal
weiter mit dem caravan
das ist ja auch asien da ist einfach gar
keine größere drückte so heftig mit viel
zucker ist da drin da schmeckt irgendwie
so als wäre das 50
accra sid auf jeden fall geil aus aber
dafür nicht gesehen schon besser jetzt
nicht gefallen er riecht auf jeden fall
hat
[Musik]
american zuschauer letzten ich hab mal
wieder was leckeres getrunken
mir fehlen die worte ehrlich ist heftig
das müsste immer probiert haben ich habe
jetzt auch überhaupt keinen dass ich
kein geld mehr da so ein banker blick
falsches aber das ist der schritt
ehrlich welcher sie habt ihr bock zur
fraktions mädchen wie zu arbeiten
schickt mir einfach ihren monat 100
stück vorbei und die stelle einfach mal
direkt doch im kasten
ich möchte mein vermieter diese energie
von diesem ganzen zeug in meinem körper
geht jetzt probieren immer zum schluss
dass in monza ich habe auch welcher ist
dass ich doppelt ist der standard drink
von denen von denen habe ich mal ein
getrunken ich fange ich okay aber das
heißt halt nicht der standard trink mal
probiert der schmeckt so nah
aufgeweichten gummibärchen also müsste
ich jetzt den ganzen zeug die punkte
verteilt würde ich den hier
acht von zehn punkten geben wenn ihr
drei von zehn
demir 15 und dem jetzt sehen von zehn
ganz klar als das ist echt der über
schickt man so hat das energy drink
currywurst teil
wie kommt man auf die idee einen energy
drink zu machen der nach currywurst aber
was hat mein erster gedanke ist das ist
doch überhaupt nicht der unrat fördern
so was mache ich mein werk wenn sie
bitte ein ende seiner club med
walter meier auch jetzt wieder auf volle
kraft jetzt bin ich mal gespannt was von
lecker.de schreibst du scheiße ich kotz
gleich woher soll das wär wär würde ich
den trick dass print inhalte also dass
sie sind auf jeden fall zwei welten zehn
von zehn minuten ziehen und das täglich
wird das kann man auf jeden fall mit dem
ethischen hüten darf wie nie gedruckt
auf vergleichen
jetzt ist die welt wieder in ordnung ja
ich würde sagen ihr könnt ja auch meine
kommentare frei haben wir hier irgendwas
von den beiden probiert oder effekte
dann der schreib doch mal wie ihr das
fangen oder bestellt sich einfach mal
ausprobiert ansonsten schon am anfang
gesagt wenn ihr bock habt dass sich noch
andere produkte aus verschiedenen
ländern miteinander vergleiche dann mach
ich das
und die kommentare was ich dann da wird
hätte ich bin gespannt jack mines netz
ab bis kurz eingeblendet wird mich
freuen wenn einer mal vorbeischaut und
wir sehen uns am mittwoch wieder auf
sein haus habe ich lieb und ich hoffe